new in theaters this weekend skyscraper
and Hotel Transylvania 3 summer vacation
this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
I hope you're ready for the most summer
blockbuster II movie maybe ever made
skyscraper out this weekend brings a
whole new meaning to throwing rocks at
windows Dwayne plays the role of former
FBI hostage rescue team leader and war
veteran will Sawyer who finds himself in
a situation where he must rescue his
family from a burning skyscraper called
the Pearl after it's been taken over by
terrorists John McClane would be proud
to make it even better
Neph Hamill reprises her skills playing
a kick-ass strong female character ala
Sydney from scream as the mother of the
trapped family Sarah Sawyer this movie
is for you if you love movie jam-packed
with back-to-back action Dwayne Johnson
as a hero slash family man is what you
smell when the rock is cooking or if
you're looking for a way to get over
your fear of heights from the comfort of
a movie if you're looking for a vacation
from your summer vacation take the
family to Hotel Transylvania 3 summer
vacation the third installment of the
Hotel Transylvania series follows
monster friends and monster family of
Dracula the vampire patriarch and
hospitality industry professional as
they embark on their summer vacation
cruise though full of monsters this
movie isn't supposed to be scary and it
wasn't this 3d animation comedy from
Sony Pictures animation is voiced by a
bunch of notable names Adam Sandler Andy
Samberg Selena Gomez Kevin James David
Spade steepest Jimmy keegan-michael key
Molly Shannon Fran Drescher Kathryn Hahn
Jim Gaffigan and comedy legend Mel
Brooks not only does this film deliver
on the family-friendly labs but it also
touches on some important themes so all
these things that are 10 they tend to be
scary to kids like monsters we make
light of them and show
them has purchased regular families that
are going through the same things this
movie is for you if you're looking for a
positive family-friendly film you're a
fan of the other Hotel Transylvania
films or if you're looking to get over
your fear of monsters from the comfort
of a movie theater that's your weekend
ticket time to face your fears go see
some movies and check back next week for
Mamma Mia here we go again scary
[Music]